thank you
it might look familiar but this isn't
tennis
it's not ping pong either
and it's not badminton
so what is pickleball pickleball is a
very popular sport in America over 15
million people play in thousands of
pickleball courts that are popping up
all over America pickleball is the
buzzword everyone's talking pickerball
here in Scotland they're not just
talking about it these players are
practicing for the inaugural National
pickleball championship
just listen to how easy it was to get
here
saw this be like for a stupid name what
is that and thankfully it was pickleball
now discovered oh I quite fancy that I
tried it once and loved it and played
ever since I played tennis and I love my
tennis but tennis court is a big area to
get around in in a wheelchair
the rules are simple underarm serves
only
[Music]
each team has to play their first shot
of a bounce and no volleying is allowed
in the zone closest to the net they call
it the kitchen the kitchen area is like
a seven foot deep area either side of
the net and if the ball if you're
standing in it like you are now you
cannot hit the ball in the air
[Applause]
but the net is two inches shorter and
it's more of a paddle than a racket and
when you play doubles you're much closer
to your teammates
this is one of the fastest growing
sports in the world did you see my Roger
Federer backhand there
there are 10 000 registered players here
in Scotland
the national pickleball Championship
takes place this weekend and just in
case you are wondering there are no
pickles involved Sadia chowdry Sky News
in Glasgow